[Musique]
oui bien à part à l'automne si c'est
melissa maulin depuis cette semaine vous
pouvez imaginer qu'il ya une nouvelle
qu'on peut pas ignorer qui en fait des
médias qui continuent d'être même à
l'avant plan des métiers au québec et
c'est le cas du racisme systémique dans
les soins de santé et pas seulement dans
les soins de santé mais malheureusement
avec ce qu'on a pu voir par rapport aux
codes jocelyne ottawa qui a été au
centre des nouvelles au centre des
médias
je pense qu'il faut que je revienne
encore sur ce sujet parce que ce
traitement important pourquoi parce que
j'ai vu malheureusement des traitements
médiatiques des réactions en ligne
des discussions qui avaient lieu et qui
faisait en sorte qu'on fait ressortir
une problématique je dirais de violences
psychologiques dont on ne parle pas
encore beaucoup au québec puisqu'on
utilise encore énormément le terme en
anglais gaz lighting certains les termes
francophone qu'on veut utiliser comme le
décervelage que j'aime moins c'est comme
si on enlevait à la femme ce qui a
peut-être pensé je préfère utiliser le
détournement cognitifs
c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire plier ou
pencher la compréhension de la personne
qui était victime d'une agression
sexuelle une agression violente de
violence psychologique d'actes de
racisme et de faire pencher
l'interprétation de cet événement leur
en faveur de la personne qui aurait été
l'agresseur ou la pudeur ou la personne
qui aurait dit des choses qui sont
racistes pour la victime
donc pourquoi est ce que c'est important
d'en parler aujourd'hui c'est que dans
les médias on voit comment c'est
interprété commencé mis de l'avant comme
on utilise des plateformes pour pouvoir
interpréter ce que madame ottawa a donné
comme témoignage sur son média social
personnelles sur facebook et faut pas
oublier que cette femme au pot osé
porter plainte ou aller de l'avant parce
que justement je comprends un peu d'où
ça vient ça vient du fait qu'en nos
jupes pantalons ne l'ont pas jamais été
entendu jamais d'écouter il fallu qu'on
est un cas comme celui de joyce et
chaque one peau même toit mettre de
l'avant
l'idée qu'il ya une problématique au
québec alors il faut live stream et des
cas extrêmes en ligne pour pouvoir même
faire croire que c'est un moment qui
peut être vécu d'une certaine manière
par un pan de la population
bien sûr ça faire revenir en avant un
plan la discussion autour de hashtag
racisme systémique pourquoi est ce que
le premier ministre en parle pas mais ce
qui était fantastique à travers cet
événement là c'est la réaction très
rapide du grand public très rapide aussi
du système de corriger la problématique
qui la touchaient et pourquoi je dis une
réaction rapide c'est que les deux
infirmières ont été congédiés celles qui
avaient le mauvais goût dans votre clé
joyce donc pour imaginer comment cette
question cette déclaration ne peut être
chargée émotionnellement mais aussi
d'une façon très violente envers la
personne qui reçoit que s'appeler
jocelyne donc est ce que c'est une
menace
est-ce que c'est au ridicule is le décès
ou la mort de quelqu'un mais dans les
métiers on voit aussi avec le
représentant du site fille qui dit mais
non mais il vous la voulez prendre un
contact avec la personne donc essayer de
détourner commence et interpréter
commencé vécue par une personne qui vit
du racisme au point qu'elle ne porte pas
plainte parce que il faut garder espoir
de pouvoir dire je te fais avoir une
justice réellement est-ce que je
m'expose à plus de quolibets raciste
surtout avec une période comme celui des
médias sociaux qui s'y présentent dans
la discussion il faut faire attention
comment ça va être les diamants et
comment savait aussi utilisé par part du
public pour prendre justifier que
maintenant on s'est trompé ah ben non
elle a mal interprété
il y en a pas de racisme système et
surtout quand on est encore au point
zéro de la discussion ou est ce qu'il
faut faire accepter de dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont par le premier
ministre du québec et d'ailleurs c'est
une des remarques est ressorti beaucoup
pourquoi est-ce qu'au québec on est les
seuls à refuser de nommer le racisme
systémique alors que c'est fait dans les
autres provinces alors que ces fêtes aux
états unis il ya des endroits où
justement des problématiques de
discriminations de racisme aussi sont
très flagrant pour nous québec mais
qu'on en fait un peu plus de difficultés
faire un examen de conscience par
rapport à nos propres pratiques pendant
notre propre système et de nommer les
choses telles qu'elles sont de dire ceci
du racisme estime maintenant comment je
peux mettre en place des lois des
règlements justement des structures
quant au sein des services de santé il
ya rien d événements comme celui-ci
pour l'instant on va voir quelque chose
qui va un petit peu à larache mais il
faut mettre en place un correcteur pour
ce système l'info pour le nommer donc on
est encore au point zéro mais cependant
je dirais que c'est point zéro pour ce
qui est du système mais par exemple à
part ce qui est de la communauté parce
que des personnes allochtone qui ont
commencé à se lever dans l'immédiat a
décrit justement le racisme systémique
je dirais que je suis quand même assez
impressionné j'ai vu dans des grands
médias des personnes qui ont des postes
quand même assez avancée des vedettes
québécoises se porte à la défense
justement des enjeux qui touchent à la
systémique chez prada nation et là on
parle même pas juste des premières
nations on va parler aussi des personnes
qui sont afro descendantes présentement
on voit une montée de la violence envers
des personnes d'origine asiatique à
cause du creux vide
donc ce sont des enjeux qu'on doit
délester de notre société et qu'on doit
pouvoir amener des solutions et dans les
normands eh bien on s'offre une chance
de changer ce système là pour devenir la
société qu'on pense et qu'on rêve de
devenir aussi alors je vous souhaite une
belle semaine malgré tous les évènements
qui se passe en ce moment je nous
souhaite de la solidarité
n'hésitez pas à vous envoie nous envoyer
vos questions n'hésitez pas surtout à
partager cette chronique et vous pouvez
me retrouver sur plusieurs plateformes
en format podcast donc je vous êtes une
personne